in the days leading up to Philippine
president Rodrigo Duterte s fifth visit
to China he took a firm stance on what
will be discussed saying that he'd
cancelled a trip if he could not talk
about the 2016 World Court tribunal
ruling over China's territorial claims
in the South China Sea it sided with the
Philippines China rejects the ruling
Duterte enjoys an approval rating of
about 80 percent but he's facing
pressure over what critics say is an
increasingly close relationship with
China he's called it a delicate
balancing act when Chinese President Xi
Jinping visited the Philippines late
last year billions of dollars in
investment were promised most of it has
yet to materialize I think the question
for today is how much sovereignty is he
willing to concede in order to get this
money and if the money is not turning up
or China's slow with the money or these
projects are not what they've been hyped
to be then you've got you know then that
adds another complicating factor in June
a Chinese vessel rammed a philippine
fishing boat 22 Filipino fishermen were
left floating in the sea they were
rescued by a Vietnamese boat the public
was angered by the incident
president duterte viewed it as minor his
china visit comes at a time according to
a recent study more than half of
Filipinos surveyed have little trust in
China but some feel despite this now is
the time to draw China closer
Philippines has to take advantage of a
situation you should capitalize on
opportunities the opportunity now is
there is a trade war going on between
China and the US with tariffs
continuously rising time to move in so
while president Duterte may say he's
standing up for the Philippine people
and their interests he will ultimately
be judged on what he can actually get
from China in terms of territorial
agreements and promised investment
dollars scott Heidler al Jazeera Beijing